I'm going to teach you about a spinning ball except it's not a ball and it's not spinning today in Kiss kit in the
classroom we'll talk about this Quantum property called spin by looking at the experiment that first found evidence for
it welcome to kkit in the classroom in this series we'll use kit to explore some fundamental concepts commonly
covered in Quantum Computing related courses each video will also be accompanied by an interactive module
Linked In the description below so be sure to check that out today we're talking about the 1922 Stern gerlock
experiment it's one of the most famous in the history of quantum theory because it's so plainly demonstrates how Quantum
spin works but that's not what Stern or gerlock intended to show the experiment was designed to test a new Quantum model
of the atom called the bore model named after Neil's bore who proposed it in 1913 in the model electrons went around
the nucleus in discrete orbitals and they could transition between those orbitals by absorbing or emitting
photons each orbital had a quantized angular momentum that was an integer multiple of a tiny fundamental constant
called H back in the 1910s and early 20s quantum mechanics was brand new so new
that it wasn't even called quantum mechanics yet so not everyone was con convinced of the warar model a physicist
named Otto Stern hated it he called the model nonsense and even went as far as threatening to quit physics if bore were
proven right stern was so intent on proving the model wrong he came up with an ingenious way to test it and
recruited Walther gerlock to help him design and conduct the experiment turns out he didn't prove bore wrong he ended
up proving himself wrong their experiment was so simple and the results so Stark it pretty much settled the
debate quantum mechanics rules at the atomic scale they didn't realize it at the time
but Stern and gerlocks experiment also found conclusive evidence for an electron's intrinsic spin which was a
new fundamental property of nature that is essential to explain magnetism super conductivity and much of
chemistry today I'll walk you through how the stern gerlock experiment Works what we would classically expect to see
from the experiment and what Stern and gerlock ended up finding then I'll show you how you can run your own Stern
gerlock type experiment with kcit and an IBM quantum computer the basic idea of the stern
gerlock experiment was to find a way to determine if the angular momentum of an electron in an atom was quantized as
bore predicted or not as Stern expected they used the fact that the electron's angular momentum would also cause there
to be a little magnetic field around each atom so so you can think of them as Tiny bar
magnets the experiment looked like this there was an oven full of silver
atoms and a magnetic field with the North and South Poles
here the field was Stronger near the top and weaker near the bottom so it produced a gradient pointing upward
finally there was a screen in the experiment the oven heated up silver atoms until they evaporated and then
they flew out of the oven with the orientation of each atom's little bar magnet completely random then the atoms
pass through the magnetic field the atoms would be pushed up or down with a force that depended on the direction of
each atom's North Pole relative to this field gradient then the atoms hit the screen Stern and gerlock could look at
where the atoms hit on the screen to learn about the angular momentum of the electrons Stern expected that the atoms
in the experiment would behave as I've been describing them up till now like tiny little bar magnets that obey the
rules of classical physics classically these little Atomic magnets could be oriented in any random Direction so as
they travel through the magnetic field they could experience a range of different forces pushing them up or down depending on those orientations a magnet
pointing in the same direction as the gradient would experience a large Force up upward in the opposite direction it'd
experience a large Force downward and if it was somewhere in between it would be a weaker Force if the atom's pointing
perpendicular to the gradient then it would experience no force and it would just continues straight because of this
range of possible forces the atoms should all hit the screen at different vertical points the pattern they'd make
on the screen would look something like this but that's not all what Stern and
gerlock saw instead they saw two entirely separate Blobs of atoms on the screen with no atoms in the
center they didn't have the correct Theory at the time to explain this but we now know that they saw this because
every electron has some amount of intrinsic angular momentum in the form of spin which can only ever take on one
of two values in our bar magnet picture this means there are only two allowed orientations of the atom magnets we call
these two orientations spin up and spin down a cubit in a quantum computer
resembles this type of spin system and some quantum computers actually use cubits made from the electron spin
States so we can perform our own Stern gerlock experiment with kcit and the cubits in an IBM quantum computer let's
map the spin up state of the electron to be the zero state of the Cubit and the spin down state to be the one state
State on the Cubit when the silver particles came out of the oven they had randomly oriented magnetic moments we
can model the stern gerlock experiment by creating a simple Quantum circuit with a single Cubit starting in the zero
state so this is called a circuit diagram where the top wire is the Cubit and the operations applied to the Cubit
show up as boxes on the wire the RX and the RZ boxes are quantum Gates that
effectively rotate the magnetic Orient ation of the atom we can choose random Theta and F values here to rotate the
Cubit a random amount this mimics the oven which spits the atoms out with random spin orientations the gray box is
our measurement it tells us if the Cubit is in the state zero or one and sends that measurement to a classical bit the
double line labeled C this part is equivalent to measuring whether the atom is in spin up or spin down by looking at
which spot it hits on the screen we can use a kuit primitive called sampler to run the experiment many times each with
different random values for Theta and f after 100 samples we get a measurement histogram that looks like this around
50% of the time the Cubit is measured to be zero and 50% of the time it's in state 1 this is the same result Stern
and gerlock saw it's always either spin up or spin down but never in between at this point you may be thinking well of
course we got two discret results We performed the experiment on a digital quantum computer which only ever returns
zero or one and this is true but keep in mind that the entire reason quantum computers return binary results in fact
why Quantum Computing works at all is exactly because this spin quantization that Stern and gerlock first discovered
the cubits in IBM quantum computers are not based on spins but many other quantum computers are so performing a
Stern gerlock experiment on a quantum computer allows us to actually ReDiscover spin quantization
since 1922 countless extensions to the original Stern gerlock experiment have been performed these extensions involve
sending the same beam of atoms through multiple Stern gerlock apparatuses to see how the spins behave in different
scenarios here's one let's send the atoms through one apparatus to separate the beam into two corresponding to a
spin up beam and a spin down beam and then send each of those beams through their own separate
apparatuses with kcit the quantum circuit corresponding to this experiment is similar to the last one but with two
measurements instead of one here we've replaced the random rotations that mimicked the effect of the oven with a
gate called a hadamard since applying the hadamard will give us the same measurement probabilities as the oven
did but it's much simpler to use so we measure once and then twice and the
resulting measurement histogram for the experiment looks like this where the bit strings on the X AIS correspond to the
outcomes of the two measurements if the Cubit was measured zero both times that corresponds to the 0 0 bit string or if
it was measured first zero then one that corresponds to one Zer and so on it looks like if it was measured spin up in
the first experiment it will be spin up in the second same with the spin down atoms that means in the first experiment
we had equal ability of measuring up or down but by the second experiment the outcome was already determined so the
two screens at the end of each of the second Stern GAC apparatuses would each only have one spot one screen would have
all the spin up atoms and one screen would have all the spin down atoms for our next experiment let's
start with a beam of purely spin up atoms with an actual physical Stern GAC experiment you could do this by sending
them through a Stern GAC apparatus and blocking the beam that's deflected down so all the atoms deflected upward are
spin up now let's send this beam through another Stern gerlock apparatus but this time let's rotate the magnets 90° so
that the field gradient will deflect the atoms that are traveling this way to the left or to the right instead would we
see one spot or two or something completely different for this experiment
we'll run the following circuit on kcit we'll start in the zero State since our beam of atoms in this experiment are all
spin up then this hadamard gate exchanges the x and z coordinates so that it has the effect of rotating the
stern GAC apparatus so now we're measuring the spin projection left or right instead of up or down here we get
the measurement histogram that looks like this so we can see that the spin along X can also only take on two values
which we can call spin left and spin right so this experiment shows that if you measure the X projection of a spin
that was previously measured to be spin up along Z it will be spin left or right with equal probability let's contrast
this one last time to classical expectation just to really highlight the difference classically remember that I
said that if the little Atomic bar magnet was pointing perpendicular to the magnetic field gradient of the apparatus
the force on that atom should be zero it shouldn't be deflected up or down in that case we just see a single spot in
the middle of the screen instead we see two spots so half the atoms have spin left and half have spin right even
though they were previously measured to be up so from a quantum mechanical perspective while it may be tempting to
equate spin up with a vector pointing up and spin down with one pointing down it's not as simple as this as we can see
from the last experiment to really understand what's going on here we'll need to go deeper into the topics of
quantum superposition and measurement which will be a video for another day just as we're left with more
questions about how exactly quantum mechanics works so were Stern and gerlock their experiment didn't explain
everything but it went a long way in establishing quantum mechanics as essential to understanding the natural
world it was one of the most important foundational experiments in quantum mechanics that both proved quantization
of momentum and provided evidence for a new fundamental property of nature called spin to really grapple with and
understand the rules of the quantum World physicists like Stern and gerlock had to get their hands dirty designing
experiments making predictions and sometimes being wrong there really is no replacement for trying things yourself
so if you want to try your hand at running some real Quantum experiments head over to the stern gerlock module
Linked In the description thanks for watching and I'll see you next time